Je sais ce que vous vous pensez.
« Pas moyen que ce mec se tienne là-devant et défende cet organisme. »
Je ne sais pas pour vous, mais je ne veux pas vivre dans un monde
où les lumières crues et fluorescentes,
les files d'attente sans fin,
les horribles formulaires à remplir
et les bureaucrates mécontents et sans âme me rappellent
que je suis chanceux de ne pas travailler là.
(Rires)
C'est le vrai service qu'ils fournissent.
L'organisme des permis :
venez pour renouveler votre immatriculation,
restez pour la satisfaction de savoir
que vous avez fait de bons choix dans la vie.
(Rires)
Personne n'aura de voiture à l'avenir
et donc les adolescents n'auront pas d'endroit où se peloter.
Vous comprenez.
Ils appelleront des voitures autonomes pour faire ça.
Je ne veux pas entrer dans un véhicule et me demander :
« Pourquoi cette voiture sent-elle la gêne, l'échec et la honte ? »
(Rires)
Si je veux me poser cette question, j'irai dans ma chambre.
Que pouvons-nous espérer d'autre ?
Oui, l'intelligence artificielle.
L'intelligence artificielle.
Il fut une époque
où l'intelligence artificielle était une blague.
Une boutade que vous entendiez lors d'une soirée cocktail
quand quelqu'un l'abordait dans la conversation :
« L'intelligence artificielle.
La seule intelligence artificielle est notre Congrès aux États-Unis.
Ah ah ah ah ah. »
Ce n'est plus amusant.
(Rires)
Stephen Hawking, Elon Musk et Bill Gates ont tous publiquement exprimé
de graves réserves sur l'intelligence artificielle.
C'est comme si Jésus, Moïse et Mahomet se réunissaient et disaient :
« Voici une chose en laquelle nous pouvons tous croire. »
(Rires)
Vous devriez peut-être suivre ce qu'ils disent.
Nous apprenons à des machines à penser,
à comprendre notre comportement,
à se défendre et même à tromper.
Qu'est-ce qui pourrait mal se passer ?
(Rires)
La seule chose qui est certaine :
la création méprise toujours son créateur.
D'accord ?
Les Titans se sont soulevés contre les dieux ;
Lucifer contre Jehovah.
Et tous ceux ayant un adolescent ont entendu ces mots :
« Je te déteste et tu me gâches la vie !
Je te déteste ! »
Imaginez ce sentiment avec une machine qui peut réfléchir plus que vous
et est lourdement armée.
(Rires)
Le résultat ?
Absolument.
(Rires)
Avant de perfectionner l'intelligence artificielle,
nous devons perfectionner les émotions artificielles.
Nous pourrons ainsi apprendre aux robots ou aux machines
à nous aimer inconditionnellement,
pour que quand ils découvriront que le seul vrai problème sur Terre
c'est nous,
au lieu de nous détruire --
ce qui, au passage, est tout à fait logique --
ils nous trouvent adorables --
(Rires)
comme le caca de bébé.
« J'adore la façon dont vous avez détruit la planète.
Je ne peux pas rester en colère, vous êtes si mignons !
Vous êtes si mignons ! »
(Rires)
Je ne peux pas parler de cela sans parler de robotique.
Vous pensiez que la robotique, c'était cool ?
J'ai pensé que la robotique était cool
jusqu'à ce que je réalise que les robots allaient prendre nos places,
du livreur au chirurgien cardiaque.
La chose qui est très décevante au sujet des robots
est le Graal de la robotique mais ça n'est jamais arrivé.
Je parle de la copine robot,
le rêve du geek esseulé dans une cave sans fenêtre
qui a un jour promis : « J'épouserai ma création ».
Il y a un mouvement pour empêcher cela d'arriver,
par peur de l'exploitation.
Je suis contre ce mouvement.
Je crois que nous devrions avoir des copines robots.
Je crois juste qu'elles devraient être livrées avec un protocole féministe
et une intelligence artificielle
afin qu'elle puisse regarder ce mec et dire : « Je suis trop bien pour toi.
Je pars. »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Pour finir,
je dois parler de bio-ingénierie,
un domaine de la science qui promet
de mettre un terme à la maladie avant même qu'elle ne commence,
de nous aider à vivre des vies plus longues, plus remplies, plus saines.
Associez cela à un matériel implantable
et vous avez sous les yeux
la prochaine incarnation de l'évolution humaine.
Tout cela semble génial,
jusqu'à ce que vous compreniez où cela mène.
Une chose :
les bébés sur mesure
où, peu importe où vous êtes sur la planète
ou quelle est votre ethnie,
les bébés ressembleront à cela.
(Rires)
Le garçon est surpris
car il vient de découvrir que ses deux parents sont noirs.
(Rires)
Pouvez-vous l'imaginer à une soirée cocktail dans 20 ans ?
« Mes deux parents sont noirs.
C'est parfois un peu embarrassant,
mais ma cote de solvabilité
est impressionnante, très impressionnante. »
(Rires)
Tout cela semble effrayant
et tout le monde ici sait que ça ne l'est pas.
La technologie n'est pas effrayante.
Elle ne l'a jamais été et ne le sera jamais.
Ce qui est effrayant, c'est nous
et ce que nous ferons de cette technologie.
Lui permettrons-nous d'exposer notre humanité,
de montrer qui nous sommes véritablement
et de renforcer le fait que nous sommes les gardiens de nos frères ?
Ou lui permettrons-nous de révéler nos démons les plus profonds et sombres ?
La vraie question n'est pas : est-ce que la technologie est effrayante ?
La vraie question est :
à quel point êtes-vous humain ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)